.
Es gibt Träume im Leben,
die lassen sich nur realisieren,
wenn der Mensch
über sich hinauswächst.
Und davon handelt diese Geschichte.
Imposante,
eindrückliche Chor-Musik
Vom Traum von Piloten und Rettern,
in der Welt der 8'000er des Himalaya
eine Rettungsstation aufzubauen.
Dafür fliegen sie
in die Todeszone bis auf 7'000 m.
Ja, es wird nicht einfach,
mein lieber Freund,
es wird nicht einfach.
Sie trainieren und testen
in eisiger Höhe auf über 6'000 m,
in dünner Luft.
Es geht schon.
Man muss nur langsam arbeiten.
Sie retten Leben.
Hast du beide dran?
Nein, nur einen.
Manchmal kommt jede Hilfe zu spät.
Und alles droht zu scheitern,
als 2 Bergretter bei einem Einsatz
eine Eiswand touchieren und Tausende
von Metern in den Tod stürzen.
Trotzdem
halten sie an ihrem Traum fest.
Das ist ihre Geschichte.
Sanft-imposante Musik
Als der Zermatter Pilot Gerold Biner
und der Rettungsspezialist Bruno Jelk
in Kathmandu landen,
ist ihnen nicht bewusst, dass dieses
Abenteuer ihr Leben verändern wird.
Am Flughafen von Kathmandu
treffen die Zermatter
auf ihre nepalesischen Partner
von Fishtail Air.
Namaste!
Die Rettungsspezialisten aus der
Schweiz sind eines von mehreren Teams
welche die Piloten von Fishtail Air
zu Bergrettern ausbilden wollen.
Diese flogen bis anhin nur leichte
Rettungen oder Touristenflüge.
Das ist ein neuer Heli.
Man sieht hier, 8/2009.
Er hat schon etwas gelitten,
Wir mussten an manchen Orten
etwas verstärken.
Aber das ist ... tipptopp.
Vertraust du diesen Leuten?
Absolut.
Die meisten haben selber Familie und
wollen sich nicht gleich umbringen.
Wiedersehen mit dem Piloten,
auf den sie ihre Hoffnung setzen:
Sabin Basnyat,
32 Jahre, Familienvater.
Mit ihm flogen die Retter
der Air Zermatt vor einem halben Jahr
eine Rettungsaktion im Himalaya
auf 6'400 m.
Er ist einer der erfahrensten Piloten
Nepals, mit über 6'000 Flugstunden.
Gemeinsam setzen sie ihren Weg fort -
nach Lukla,
dem Tor zum Everestgebiet.
Es liegt auf 2'860 m.
Hier soll die Basis
der Rettungsstation entstehen.
Lukla ist ein kleines Dorf
im Distrikt Solo Khumbu,
vorwiegend bewohnt von Sherpas,
einem Volksstamm, der aus Tibet
nach Nepal eingewandert ist.
Die Bevölkerung lebt vom Tourismus -
die meisten sind Händler
oder Lastenträger,
die Westler
auf die 8'000er bringen.
Sanfte, orientalische Musik
Der Flughafen gilt mit
seiner geneigten Start- und Landebahn
als einer
der gefährlichsten der Welt.
Aber hier muss jeder durch,
der einen 8'000er besteigen
oder ein Trekking machen will.
Auch Bruno war schon mehrmals hier,
und doch ist diesmal
alles etwas anders:
Am Ende meiner Rettungskarriere
war es eine Herausforderung,
in Nepal, in den hohen Bergen
etwas aufzuziehen und zu helfen.
Das war
eine persönliche Herausforderung.
Leute zu retten
und nicht nur Leichen zu bergen.
Der Reiz an der Sache war, dass es
so was bis anhin nicht gegeben hat.
Das war etwas ganz Neues.
Das war für uns
eine gewaltige Herausforderung.
Bevor es losgeht,
will der Nepali Pilot Sabin
seinem Zermatter Kollegen Gerold
die Schönheiten
des Everestgebietes zeigen.
Wir heben ab Richtung Gokyo.
Höhe 4'800 m.
Während der Saison im Frühling ist er
hier täglich mit Touristen unterwegs.
Zudem erinnert ihn die Landschaft
an ein Kindheitserlebnis mit seinem
Vater, der Helikoptermechaniker war.
Ich war als kleiner Junge
einmal hier oben, mit meinem Vater.
In einem Helikopter.
Von der Armee?
Ja, einem Armeehelikopter.
Wir waren in Lukla gestartet
und als wir
durch dieses Tal flogen ―
ich war zuvor
noch nie in den Bergen gewesen ―
da hatte ich so richtig Angst.
Ich sass direkt neben meinem Vater
und klammerte mich an ihn.
Du warst sehr beeindruckt.
Ja.
Sanfte, orientalische Musik
Das ist fantastisch.
Die Sonne kommt hervor,
all diese Gipfel ...
Ein Traum
für einen Helikopterpiloten.
Auf einer Flughöhe von knapp 6'000 m
erheben sich vor ihnen
die schroffen Gipfel
des Sagarmatha Nationalparks -
die 8'000er Everest und Lhotse -
neben sich Bergsteiger
auf dem Weg zum Gipfel des Lobuje.
Unsere Berge erscheinen im Gegensatz
dazu wie im Suisse Miniature.
Das ist so gewaltig
und beeindruckend,
die Grösse der Berge und Gletscher.
Das ist etwas,
das ich nie mehr vergessen werde.
Am nächsten Morgen wird es ernst.
Was Piloten und Rettungsspezialisten
heute vorhaben,
ist ein Flug ans absolute Limit.
Sie wollen auf 7'000 m fliegen,
die Maximalhöhe für die
der Helikopter zugelassen ist.
Gerold ist angespannt.
Ein kleiner Fehler,
könnte die Katastrophe bedeuten.
Die Bergretter wollen herausfinden,
ob Rettungen in dieser Höhe
überhaupt möglich sind.
Okay. Ja, ich spüre den Sauerstoff.
Die Luft ist auf 7'000 m so dünn,
dass die Piloten
ohne Sauerstoff ohnmächtig würden.
Ein Absturz wäre die Folge.
Links ist es okay.
Rechts ist es okay.
Dann gehts hoch.
Der Test führt sie zum Mount Everest,
dem höchsten Berg der Welt.
Man muss sich bewusst sein,
dass man an der Grenze der Power,
der Leistung ist.
D.h., das Triebwerk
gibt einfach nicht mehr Leistung,
der Helikopter steigt nicht mehr.
Wenn ich im Vorwärtsflug bin,
brauche ich weniger Leistung
als wenn ich im Schwebeflug bin.
Wenn der Helikopter nicht mehr hält,
sinkt er langsam.
Er fällt nicht wie ein Stein.
Aber er sinkt langsam.
Das sind Dinge,
die einem bewusst sein müssen.
Dafür muss man
genügend Platz lassen.
Im Gegensatz zur Fliegerei hier
muss man dort
noch mehr Reserve einpacken.
Schau dir das Licht an ... wow!
Wir wiegen etwa 300 kg.
Das ist okay.
Weit unter ihnen liegt schon bald das
Basislager des Everests auf 5'340 m.
Eine Zeltstadt
mit Hunderten von Bergsteigern.
Hier spürst du die Abwinde.
Ein Schwebeflug
wäre hier wohl kaum möglich.
Hoch hinaus!
Wir sind etwa auf der Höhe
von Camp 2 würde ich sagen.
Nein, wir sind viel höher,
wir sind auf 6'400.
Siehst du da? Der Everest.
Das ist der Nordsattel.
Vor ihnen liegt der Nordsattel
des Everest auf über 7'000 m.
Sie haben ihre Grenze erreicht.
Ja, wir sind viel höher
als Camp 1 da unten.
Wir sind jetzt
sicher schon über 7'000 m.
Jetzt kann man es spüren.
Mit einem kleinen Gerät am Finger,
dem Oxymeter,
kontrollieren sie
den Sauerstoffgehalt im Blut.
Immer noch 73.
Gut.
Körper wie auch Helikopter
sind in der dünnen Luft am Limit.
Die Turbine bringt nun nicht mehr
genug Leistung, um zu schweben.
Darf ich jetzt übernehmen,
ist das für dich in Ordnung?
Ich würde geradeaus fliegen,
falls etwas geschehen sollte.
Wir weichen zur rechten Seite aus.
Flieg langsam!
Das rechte Pedal
reagiert noch ausreichend,
aber na ja ...
Ja, ich probier
jetzt hier auszuweichen.
Langsam, kein Problem
und jetzt ziehen wir weg.
Ja, das ist nicht einfach,
so hoch zu fliegen.
Das wird nicht einfach hier
zu retten, mein lieber Freund.
Für mich war die Erkenntnis,
dass es möglich ist,
Rettungen durchzuführen,
bis an die Zertifikationsgrenze
des Helikopters, bis 7'000 m.
Aber man bewegt sich dort oben
ganz stark am Limit
und es es ist absolut
kein Fehler erlaubt.
Und auch Sabin
ist nach dem Flug zuversichtlich.
Heute waren die Windverhältnisse
etwas schwierig.
Aber wenn das Wetter gut ist,
ist eine Rettung möglich.
Damit haben die Bergretter aus der
Schweiz ein erstes Teilziel erreicht.
Mit dem Testflug
und den ersten Erfahrungen im Rücken
kehren sie zurück in die Schweiz.
Ein halbes Jahr später
beginnt die 2. Phase.
Die Ausbildung des Teams aus Nepal
in den 4'000ern um Zermatt.
Die beiden Piloten Sabin und
Siddartha sowie der Mechaniker Purna
werden hier 3 Wochen lang
intensiv geschult.
Denn was ihnen fehlt,
ist v.a. spezifisches Know-how
und die Routine.
Gerold bläut dem Team ein, dass es
bei Rettungsaktionen lernen muss,
zusammen zu kommunizieren
und warnt sie.
The take-off and the landing
with persons on board ...
Siddartha und Sabin,
die beiden Piloten,
sowie Purna,
den angehenden Bergretter.
Zuerst müsst ihr
sicheren Stand haben.
Als nächstes klinkt ihr euch aus und
sagt "Seil frei", wenn es frei ist.
Es ist schön, macht Spass,
aber es ist tückisch.
Ihr werdet hier
ein Basiswissen erwerben,
aber bringt euch
bitte nicht in Gefahr!
Es muss nur etwas falsch laufen,
und schon befindet ihr euch
in einer sehr kritischen Situation.
Sie haben eine solide Grundbasis
aus flugtechnischer Sicht.
Was sie noch nie
oder nur wenig gemacht haben,
sind die Unterlastflüge,
das sind die Rettungen mit dem Seil.
Da haben sie keine Erfahrung.
In der Schweiz, wo man das
seit 40 Jahren praktiziert,
konnte man sich viel Erfahrung
aneignen.
Und genau das wollen wir:
Wir wollen diesen Leuten
diese Erfahrungen mitgeben,
nicht nur die positiven,
sondern hauptsächlich auch,
was passieren kann,
wenn unter gewissen Umständen
etwas schiefgeht.
Das ist da Hauptziel
unser Ausbildung.
Nach mehrwöchigem Training
am langen Seil, der sog. Longline,
steht der erste Härtest an.
Die beiden Piloten aus Nepal,
Sabin und Siddartha,
sollen heute
Lawinenverbauungen montieren.
Jetzt fühlen wir diesen Burschen
einmal richtig auf den Zahn.
Jetzt sind sie gefordert.
Er glaube nicht, dass es klappe.
Selbst für Schweizer Piloten sei dies
eine der schwierigsten Arbeiten,
meint Gerold.
Es ist ein Job,
bei dem es um Zentimeter geht.
Spannende Musik
Bruno Jelk wartet mit Purna, dem
angehenden Bergretter, am Landeplatz.
Purna soll lernen,
wie der Bergretter am Boden
mit dem Piloten
per Funk kommuniziert.
Spannende Musik
So, jetzt gehen wir direkt zu Jimmy.
Purna beobachtet genau und hört mit,
wie Pilot Sabin per Funk
vom Boden aus eingewiesen wird.
Okay, Sabin kannst du mich sehen?
Ich bin dein Referenzpunkt.
Okay, ich seh dich.
20 cm rauf!
Zentimetergenau muss Sabin
die tonnenschwere Last
am 30 m langen Seil absetzen.
Jetzt kannst du runter,
langsam runter mit dem Element.
Langsam, langsam!
Etwas tiefer mit dem Helikopter!
Elemente sind Okay.
Seil frei, du kannst gehen!
Jetzt gerade hoch, hoch und clear.
Das wars. Eine leichte Sache!
Das war sehr gut.
Siddartha und du -
ihr wart beide ausgezeichnet.
Und auch Purna bekommt viel Lob:
Thank you very much.
Vielen Dank.
Das Training ist ausgezeichnet.
Du machst das gut,
wirklich gute Arbeit. Vielen Dank.
Um ehrlich zu sein,
ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass es funktioniert, verzeiht mir!
Hey, das war super!
You did a great job!
Wir kommunizieren jetzt
in Zentimetern.
Ja, das ist ein gutes Gefühl.
Am nächsten Morgen ist Purna
mit Bruno im Klettergarten unterwegs.
Purna hat
noch keine grossen Kletterfahrungen
und Bruno will ihn langsam an seine
Aufgabe als Bergretter heranführen.
Versuchen wirs mal!
Es ist für mich das erste Mal.
Ich versuche es jetzt.
Bruno kommt auch mit.
Es ist ein gutes Training.
Ready?
Yes.
Slowly!
This side, Purna! From this side!
Für Purna sind Training
und Ausbildung eine grosse Chance.
Dankbarkeit, Respekt und Bewunderung
für Bruno vermischen sich bei ihm.
Ja, kommt schon gut.
All diese Erfahrungen, die ich hier
mache, sind ein Geschenk Gottes.
Ich hätte mir das nie erträumt,
und Bruno er ist mein Lehrer,
er ist mein Gott.
Purna
hat das sehr gut begriffen.
Er wusste sofort,
was er kann und was nicht.
Er zeigte auch ein sehr grosses
Interesse. Er war voll motiviert.
Es ist schön, mit solchen Leuten
zusammenzuarbeiten.
Okay, gib Gas und ab gehts!
Es handelt sich vielleicht
um einen Schwerverletzten.
Wenn es zu schwierig werden sollte,
dann übernehme ich.
Perfekt!
Ernsteinsatz für Sabin.
Gemeinsam mit dem Piloten Robi Anden-
matten holen sie Bruno zu Hause ab.
Okay, du kannst abheben!
Funkspruch:
Das ist das Bishorn.
Auf 3'800 m. Im Ostgrat.
3 Personen sind auf 3'800 m
am Ostgrat des Bishorns blockiert.
Sieht gut aus, nicht?
Wir gehen runter
und befestigen das Seil.
Die einzige Lösung ist eine Rettung
mit dem langen Seil, der Longline.
Okay, das 30er-Seil dran.
Bist du auch bereit?
Ich bin bereit, ja.
30 m unter dem Helikopter
hat sich Bruno am Seil eingehängt
und wird von Sabin zu den
blockierten Bergsteigern geflogen.
Es geht ihm gut, dem Bruno.
Er sagt, nicht höher.
Du bist noch am steigen.
Zum ersten Mal rettet Sabin
Menschen mit der Longline.
Dank dieser Technik kann er
über der Unfallstelle schweben,
ohne dass die Rotoren
zu nahe an die Bergflanke kommen
und sie touchieren könnten.
Bruno klinkt sich aus,
lässt das Seil los ... und frei.
Bruno kümmert sich unten
um die Verletzen
und bereitet sie
für den Abtransport am Seil vor.
Sie hängen dran,
wir können gehen, perfekt.
Du kannst so weiterfliegen.
Sabin muss seine Last wie geübt
zentimetergenau absetzen.
Mit dem einzigen Unterschied, dass
nun Menschen unten am Seil hängen
und ein Fehler
verheerende Folgen hätte.
Er ist frei, du kannst ziehen!
Das war sehr gut.
Du navigierst gut mit dem Spiegel,
aber du traust dich nicht,
hinunterzuschauen.
Es macht mir Angst.
Ach ja? Du hast Angst?
Möchtest du dich auf diese Seite
setzen, wo kein Fenster ist?
Tipptopp! Ich gratuliere, Sabin!
Dann fliegt Sabin auch Bruno zurück.
2, 1, slowly!
Sabins erste Longline-Rettung
ist geglückt.
Wie wars für dich, Sabin?
Die erste Longline-Rettung -
ja, es war eine schöne Erfahrung.
Was hat dich am meisten beeindruckt?
Wir waren so nahe bei den Felsen,
doch es war gut,
obschon ich
nicht hinunterschauen wollte.
Also schaute ich in den Spiegel.
Aber das kommt noch.
Ich muss einfach noch viel üben.
Als sie die Rettungen selber
gemacht haben, hat man gemerkt,
dass sie stolz sind.
Das war auch für uns
wahnsinnig befriedigend,
wenn man jemandem etwas beibringen
kann und die Dankbarkeit spürt.
Die Hoffnung,
dass man ein Level erreicht hat,
das ihnen die Sicherheit gibt,
dass sie nicht bei jedem Einsatz
im roten Bereich laufen.
Das Training in der Schweiz
ist nach 3 Wochen abgeschlossen.
Sabin und seine Kollegen
kehren nach Nepal zurück,
wo sie nun auf sich gestellt sind.
Wie weit
sind Sie in ihrer Ausbildung?
Ich glaube wir sind auf Level 1.
Und wie viele Stufen gibt es?
Ich glaube, es geht bis zur Stufe 3.
Wir sind noch am Anfang,
also bei Stufe 1, würde ich sagen.
In einem halben Jahr werden die
Zermatter wieder nach Nepal fliegen,
um die Longline-Ausbildung
im Himalaya abzuschliessen.
Bis dahin sollen Ihre nepalesischen
Freunde Rettungen alleine fliegen,
aber nichts riskieren.
Wir haben kritisch diskutiert,
auch mit den Piloten intern,
mit erfahrenen Leuten,
ob das nun der Moment sei:
Dürfen wir sie vom Haken lassen
oder noch nicht?
Was können sie machen?
Ich glaube,
Siddartha und Sabin sind Piloten,
die genügend Erfahrung haben.
Sie können abschätzen,
was geht und was nicht.
Wir haben sie oft darum gebeten,
dass sie zurückhaltend sind,
und die MERS-
oder die Human Cargo Sling,
also die Taubergung,
noch nicht einsetzen,
einfach weil die
Kommunikationsmittel noch fehlen.
Schnelle orientalische Musik
Kathmandu, Nepal, im November.
Hier im obersten Stock dieses Hauses,
das er sich gebaut hat,
lebt der angehende Bergretter Purna
mit seiner Familie,
den Kindern Rikesh,
Risav und seiner Frau Sabina.
Es ist
die Zeit der religiösen Festivals,
eine Zeit in der alle zusammensitzen
und Purna nur für die Familie da ist.
Am Anfang hielt meine Familie
meinen Job für sehr riskant
und hatte Angst.
Sie wollte mich
zum Aufhören bewegen.
Aber dann gewöhnten sie sich daran
und ich überzeugte sie ebenfalls.
Heute sind sie stolz darauf,
dass ich der erste
ausgebildete Bergretter Nepals bin.
Wenn etwas passieren sollte,
kann es eh niemand ändern.
Zuerst hatte ich Angst.
Ich war besorgt, dass etwas passiert
und ich nicht wüsste,
wie ich dann die kleinen Kinder
durchbringen würde.
Aber jetzt
habe ich mich daran gewöhnt.
Manchmal, wenn er in den Himalaya
geht, kommt in mir noch Angst auf,
aber sie verschwindet,
sobald er anruft.
Stolz zeigt Purna
seinen Söhnen die Bilder aus Zermatt.
Der gelernte Handwerker
kam vor 2 Jahren
als Mechaniker zu Fishtail Air.
Vorher war er lange arbeitslos,
dank seiner Ausbildung scheint sich
nun aber alles zum Guten zu wenden.
Ich habe Glück,
so einen Ehemann zu haben.
Er hat den besten Job der Familie.
Niemand in unserer Familie
hat mit Fliegen zu tun.
Als er arbeitslos war,
kümmerte sich niemand um ihn,
doch jetzt ist er angesehen
und alle hören auf ihn.
Doch Glück
lässt sich nicht festhalten,
und wie so oft
trifft das Unglück die,
die es am wenigsten verdient haben.
Denn, was zu dem Zeitpunkt
niemand weiss:
Es wird der letzte Abend sein, den er
mit seiner Familie verbringen wird.
Am nächsten Tag passiert das, was
alle hofften, es würde nie geschehen.
Düstere Musik
Hier an der Ama Dablam beginnt
ein Drama, das alles verändert.
An diesem Berg versuchen
die zwei erfahrenen Bergsteiger
David Göttler und Kazuya Hiraide im
November eine neue Route zu klettern.
Nach tagelangem Schneefall
bleiben sie auf 6'330 m stecken.
Per Handy rufen sie
ihre Agentur in Kathmandu an.
Dort hat sich die Ausbildung
der Bergretter von Fishtail Air
mittlerweile herumgesprochen,
sodass Sabin und Purna
zur Rettung aufgeboten werden.
Am Morgen des 7. November
nähern sie sich
den beiden Bergsteigern
und wagen
einen ersten Rettungsversuch:
Ich weiss noch,
wie der Helikopter kam.
Purna, der Assistent,
öffnete die Fronttüre
und schob die Schiebetüre
des Helikopters nach hinten.
Ich sehe noch
das Gesicht von Purna vor mir,
als er mich zum ersten Mal sah.
Er trug einen Sauerstoffschlauch
in der Nase.
Im Helikopter fühlte ich mich
sicher, er schwankte nicht.
Dann drehte der Helikopter ab
und flog runter nach Chukung.
Ich stieg dort aus,
und er flog zurück,
um meinen Partner Kazuya zu holen.
David Göttler
filmt den Berg aus sicherer Distanz -
ohne zu wissen, welche Tragödie
gleich passieren wird.
Sabin und Purna
nähern sich im Helikopter
dem Kletterpartner Kazuya.
Wie mit den Zermattern abgesprochen
machen sie keine Longline-Bergung,
sondern fliegen an die Eiskante,
um Kazuya schwebend einzuladen.
Doch plötzlich Staubwolken, der
Helikopter touchiert einen Eisblock
und stürzt mehrere 1'000 m
in die Tiefe.
Pilot Siddartha, der auch
in der Schweiz ausgebildet wurde,
fliegt als erster zur Unfallstelle,
ohne zu wissen,
dass seine Freunde
tödlich abgestürzt sind.
Das weiss zu dem Zeitpunkt
noch niemand.
Wir brauchten eine halbe Stunde,
um festzustellen,
ob unsere Freunde
lebendig oder tot waren.
Beim Schweben
sahen wir Purnas Köper zuerst.
Es war offensichtlich,
dass er tot war.
Von Sabin keine Spur.
Wir schickten Sherpas am Boden los
und sie fanden ihn schliesslich
in einer Gletscherspalte
ohne Lebenszeichen.
Als nächstes ging es darum,
die Leichen möglichst rasch
nach Kathmandu zu bringen.
Doch es war schon zu spät,
um dies noch am gleichen Tag zu tun.
Der Bergsteiger Kazuya Hiraide ist zu
diesem Zeitpunkt immer noch gefangen
auf dem Grat der Ama Dablam,
auf 6'330 m.
Erst am Abend erfuhren wir, dass
bereits ein deutscher Bergsteiger
nach Chukung in Sicherheit
gebracht worden war.
Der Unfall
geschah erst beim 2. Flug,
als sie den japanischen Bergsteiger
retten wollten.
Nun wurden wir beauftragt,
den Japaner zu retten.
Ich hatte kein gutes Gefühl dabei.
Ich wollte nicht hinfliegen,
um dort das tragische Schicksal
meiner Freunde sehen zu müssen.
Ich empfand einen gewissen Ärger
gegenüber dem Japaner,
als sei es seine Schuld,
dass sich der Unfall ereignete.
Doch das war ein kindischer Gedanke.
Nachdem er Kazuya geborgen hat,
bringt Siddartha mit dem Helikopter
seine beiden toten Freunde
von der Ama Dablam zurück.
Als die Leichen
in ein Zelt getragen werden,
erfassen die Familien langsam
die ganze Tragweite des Unfalls.
Schluchzen
Sabina, die vor 2 Tagen
mit Purna noch gefeiert hatte,
und Punam,
die Frau des Piloten Sabin,
beide stehen plötzlich
alleine mit ihren Kindern da.
Für uns war es ein absoluter Schock.
Es war genau das, was ...
... was wir alle vermeiden wollten.
Die ganze Intention dieses Projektes
bestand darin,
dass man genau diese Situation
vermeiden wollte.
Man wollte wenig Risiko eingehen
und ihnen Sicherheit geben.
Tragischerweise
geschah dann dieser Unfall.
Das ist etwas,
das wir nicht steuern können,
aber akzeptieren mussten.
Das war für uns unheimlich schwer.
In Kathmandu sollen noch am selben
Abend die Körper von Sabin und Purna
nach hinduistischer Tradition
im heiligen Schrein von Pashupatinath
verbrannt werden.
Alle Verwandten und Freunde
sind zusammengeströmt.
Purnas Körper wird
zur Verbrennungsstätte getragen.
Der Tradition entsprechend
ist nun sein 13-jähriger Sohn Rikesh
das Oberhaupt der Familie.
Purna hinterlässt seine Frau
und 2 Kinder.
Sabin findet seine letzte Ruhe
neben Purna.
Er hinterlässt seine Frau Poonam
und seine kleine Tochter Minerva (2).
Einziger Trost für die Familien
ist vielleicht,
dass die beiden
nach hinduistischem Glauben
bei einer guten Tat
ihr Leben gelassen haben
und in ihrem nächsten Leben
davon profitieren können.
Für mich war es ein grosser Verlust.
Sabin und ich sind die letzten
17, 18 Jahre zusammen geflogen.
Seit Beginn unserer Karriere.
Wir haben viel zusammen gemacht.
Auch die Ausbildung
und die Prüfungen.
Für uns alle
war es ein grosser Verlust.
Doch wir müssen weitermachen -
das war mein Gefühl.
Ein halbes Jahr später
fliegen Gerold Biner und Bruno Jelk
wie geplant zurück nach Nepal.
Trotz des Rückschlags
wollen sie mit einem neuen Team
den Aufbau der Rettungsstation
im Himalaya vorantreiben.
Mit gemischten Gefühlen
und vielen Fragen im Kopf.
Natürlich machten wir uns Vorwürfe.
Ich mir selber ganz speziell.
Denn wir führten
diese ganzen Diskussionen
mit den Pilotenkollegen.
Ab und zu kam die Meinung, dass
die beiden das nicht schaffen werden
und dass es zu früh ist.
Dass wir ein zu hohes Tempo vor-
gegeben und sie überfordert haben.
Eindrücklicher,
imposanter Chorgesang
Und wieder ist es Lukla,
dort wo mit Sabin
vor einem Jahr alles begonnen hatte,
dort wo der Traum Realität wurde
und nun weitergelebt werden soll.
Der Pilot Siddartha
soll nun Sabins Rolle übernehmen.
Bevor Siddartha und Gerold aber
an ein Training denken können,
wollen die beiden Piloten gemeinsam
mit dem Unfall abschliessen.
Sie wollen
an die Unfallstelle fliegen.
Siddartha flog seit der Tragödie
immer wieder am Schicksalsberg
seiner Freunde vorbei.
Hast du daran gedacht, aufzuhören?
Nicht wirklich.
Nach dem Unfall
wollte ich einzig eine Pause machen.
Eine Woche lang
bin ich nicht geflogen.
Nachher
war wieder ein Flug angesagt.
Was solls.
Das war ein wenig stressig. Aber ich
wollte das Fliegen nicht aufgeben.
Funkspruch
Es ist ein halbes Jahr her,
seit Sabin und Purna
an der Ama Dablam abgestürzt sind.
Ich bin etwas tief,
ich fliege höher.
Nahe an die Wolken ran!
Etwas nach links.
Always stay close to the clouds.
That's good.
Bedrohliche Musik
Schau dir das an!
Schau dir das an... Wow!
Ich steige jetzt
direkt zu Sabins Stelle hoch.
Das ist eine unglaubliche Wand!
Sind sie hier hochgeklettert
oder die Wand dahinter?
Da sind sie gegangen,
auf diesem Grat da.
Ah, okay. What a wall!
Hier Rettungen zu fliegen,
das wird eine sehr schwierige Sache!
Sie gingen also vom Grat aus hoch?
Ja, es waren ein Deutscher
und ein Japaner,
die sich auf dem Grat befanden.
Sie konnten weder hoch noch runter.
Wir erreichen 6'000 m.
Meinst du,
wir werden schweben können?
Ich glaube schon.
War es diese Kuppe da vorne?
Ja, diese Kuppe da.
Wow... was für eine Wand!
Welcher Eisblock wars,
der zweite da, der grosse?
Ja, der grosse da hinten.
Und du hast sie
auf dem unteren abgeholt?
Ja, auf dem unteren Buckel.
Es gibt dazu nicht viel zu sagen,
weisst du.
Ich glaube,
ich hätte es auch versucht,
auch du hättest es
vielleicht versucht.
Ich hätte genau dasselbe versucht.
Können wir mal runter
zu den Trümmerteilen fliegen?
Ja, klar.
Rund 2'000 m ist der Helikopter
in die Tiefe gestürzt.
Jetzt sehe ich da unten etwas.
Da ist was Rotes.
Es ist die Abdeckung
des Helikopters.
Und da ist ein zerstörtes Teil.
Ja, das ist die Abdeckung.
Ja, der Heckrotor.
Okay, fliegen wir nach Hause.
Mögen sie in Frieden ruhen.
Ja ...
Eindrücklich.
Es ist mir gelungen,
damit umzugehen,
und ich fühle mich
gar nicht so schlecht.
Wir müssen darüber hinwegkommen.
Und das Leben muss weiter gehen.
So sehe ich das.
Es war ihr Schicksal.
Ihre Zeit war abgelaufen.
Wir müssen weiter gehen,
lernen aus dem, was passiert ist
und das Beste für die Zukunft
hoffen.
Alle Last und Hoffnungen
ruhen nun auf Siddartha.
Der Druck, der auf Siddartha
lastete, als wir kamen, war enorm.
Die Erwartungen waren hoch.
Er ist jemand, der nicht viel sagt,
aber man hat es ihm angesehen.
dass es für ihn eine Belastung ist.
Er war aber so voller Enthusiasmus,
dass er gesagt hat:
"Das mache ich, das bin ich
nicht nur Sabin schuldig,
sondern das will ich auch lernen,
weil mich das weiterbringt."
Und so geht der Traum weiter.
Um die Ausbildung zu beschleunigen,
sind neben Bruno Jelk
auch der Zermatter Pilot
Dani Aufdenblatten
sowie der Rettungsspezialist
Helmut Lerjen in Lukla eingetroffen.
Der neue Bergretter im Team
heisst Tshering ―
Everestbesteiger und Bergführer.
Gemeinsam mit Bruno Jelk
macht er sich für eine Spaltenübung
auf einem Gletscher
in knapp 6'000 m Höhe bereit.
Wir haben nichts geändert,
weder am Konzept
noch an der Art der Ausbildung,
weil der Unfall mit der Ausbildung
keinen direkten Zusammenhang hatte.
Der Einsatz auf fast 6'000 m
ist auch riskant,
weil der Sauerstoffgehalt
sehr tief ist
und nicht alle so gut
akklimatisiert sind wie Tshering:
Es ist sicherlich schwierig
und gefährlich für jene,
die aus tiefen Lagen kommen.
Aber auch für uns,
doch wir sind schon viele Male
höher als 5'000 m geflogen.
Es sollte kein Problem sein.
Wir müssen aber immer
eine Ersatzflasche mit Sauerstoff
dabei haben, man weiss nie.
Innert weniger Minuten
transportieren die Piloten
das Material von 2'800 m auf 6'000 m.
Number 5, it's no problem.
Unten warten die Rettungsspezialisten
mit Bruno und Tshering.
2, 1 ... On the ground!
Okay.
That's fine.
Tshering soll heute lernen,
wie man mit modernen Hilfsmitteln
Leute sicher
aus Gletscherspalten retten kann.
Diesen dann rausziehen.
One, two, three, four, five.
Trotz der Höhe
arbeiten sie ohne Sauerstoff.
Voila.
Voila, sehr gut.
Ja, es geht schon.
Man muss einfach langsam arbeiten.
Jelk hat ein Dreibein
aus Zermatt mitgebracht.
Very important:
This X is horizontal.
Es ist eine Schweizer Entwicklung,
die schon vielen Leuten
das Leben gerettet hat
und nun im Himalaya
zum Einsatz kommen soll.
10 m tiefer hängt eine Statistin.
Tshering
wird zu Ihr hinuntergelassen.
Alles soll
so realistisch wie möglich sein.
Oh sorry, I go down.
5 m down.
Spannende Musik
Routiniert hängt Tshering
die Statistin ans Seil.
Tshering
ist mehrfacher Everestbesteiger,
stand mit Gästen
auf mehreren 8'000ern.
Er ist einer der wenigen Nepali,
der im Sommer in Europa
auch als Bergführer arbeitet.
Ein Profi.
Kabel ziehen! Sonst springt es raus.
Zieh am Kabel!
Tshering ist ein Typ,
der etwas ansieht und es kann.
Er hat gelernt zu arbeiten.
Man sieht, dass er das gelernt hat.
Er war in den Bergen unterwegs.
Wenn er etwas gesehen hat,
konnte er es sofort.
Zudem ist er sehr intelligent.
Er ist ein toller Mann.
Der kann es auf Anhieb.
Manchmal muss man ihm
ein paar Tricks zeigen,
dann kann er es.
Und das ist super. Das ist gut.
Oft war Tshering
bisher in der Situation,
dass er Leute
aus Spalten retten sollte,
ihnen aber er nicht helfen konnte,
weil die Hilfsmittel fehlten.
Es wird für uns
wirklich sehr nützlich sein,
denn wir verwendeten
bisher ein Zugsystem,
bei dem Leute oft umkommen,
denn man vergisst schnell mal,
unten Eishaken zu befestigen.
Und das Seil
kann vom Eis durchtrennt werden.
Es ist sehr gefährlich.
Ich erinnere mich an einen Fall,
als eine Bergsteigerin
herausgeholt wurde.
Da wars zuerst genau so ...
Dann versuchte man daran zu ziehen,
dabei gings kaputt,
und es war vorbei.
Aber mit diesem System
sind Retter und Opfer
deutlich voneinander getrennt
und somit ist das System
sehr sicher.
Doch ein sicheres System
reicht noch nicht aus
für eine sichere Rettung.
Nur die gemeinsame Übung,
das gemeinsame Training
zwischen Pilot und Bergretter
garantieren Sicherheit
und alle wissen, einen
2. Zwischenfall darf es nicht geben.
Wir müssen das Zusammenspiel
zwischen dem Piloten und dem Sherpa,
dem Bergretter, fördern,
das müssen sie noch trainieren.
Sie müssen auch die Möglichkeit
haben, alleine zu gehen.
Siddartha ist in der Schweiz
noch nie solo geflogen.
Er brauchte noch das Vertrauen,
dass er den Helikopter
allein steuern kann
mit einem Bergretter unten dran.
Und wir schauen von unten zu
und können Tipps geben.
Nach mehreren Tagen harten Trainings
ist es soweit:
Siddartha und Tshering haben
ihre Feuertaufe mit der Longline
auf 5'800 m vor dem Everest.
Spannende Musik
20 m über dem Boden.
10 m über dem Boden.
5 m über dem Boden.
Kontakt!
Kontakt, bleib in dieser Position!
Okay, du kannst starten.
Präzise hat Siddartha
Tshering eingehängt.
Sie fliegen gemeinsam
über das Basislager des Everest.
Starke Winde
erschweren den Einsatz zusätzlich.
Wie gehts dir, Tshering?
Okay, Captain.
Kannst du Bruno sehen,
auf unserer linken Seite?
Noch nicht.
- Okay, ich fliege dich zu Bruno.
Jetzt kann ich Bruno auch sehen.
I can see Bruno.
Okay.
Siddartha muss Tshering
bei Bruno Jelk absetzen,
der am Landeplatz steht
und alles genau beobachtet.
Es war ein gemischtes Gefühl.
Ich habe gehofft,
dass es gut funktioniert.
Wenn nochmals etwas passiert,
wird es kritisch.
Helicopter is free.
Doch plötzlich
wird aus der Übung ernst.
Mit enormer Geschwindigkeit
zieht eine gewaltige Wolkenwand
durch das Khumbutal hinauf.
Siddartha
hat Bruno und die Statistin,
die von Tshering
gerettet werden soll,
bereits vorher
auf knapp 5'800 m abgesetzt.
Nun muss alles schnell gehen.
Funkspruch
Als Tshering abhebt,
verdecken bereits Wolken und Schnee
den Everest.
Die Bergretter und das Kamerateam
drohen von den Wolken
eingeschlossen zu werden ―
auf fast 6'000 m Höhe!
In letzter Minute
gelingt die Evakuierung.
Ich hätte oben bleiben müssen.
Ich war nicht akklimatisiert.
Die Gefahr eines Lungenödems
war sehr gross.
Dann ist man fertig, weil man selber
nicht mehr zurückkommt.
Es braucht Stunden oder gar Tage,
bis man wieder auf einer Höhe ist,
die man erträgt.
Das ist Everest live,
wie Gerold sagt,
so könnte es
auch bei einem realen Einsatz gehen.
Das war jetzt gerade ziemlich heavy.
Aber ...
Er hat das solo gemacht.
May I help you?
Und damit haben die Schweizer
und Nepali Bergretter
gemeinsam eine weitere Hürde auf
dem Weg zu ihrem Traum überwunden.
Jetzt brauchst du uns nicht mehr.
Der erste Alleinflug mit Tshering
war eine wichtige Erfahrung
für mich,
denn die meisten Trainingsflüge
bin ich in geringerer Höhe geflogen.
Auf 5'500 m, allein mit der Longline
und Tshering, realisierte ich:
Ich bin fähig, die gleiche Arbeit
sogar im Himalaya zu machen.
Das war ein Wendepunkt für mich.
Eindrücklicher,
imposanter Chorgesang
Die Bewährungsprobe für Siddartha
lässt nicht lange auf sich warten.
Am Everest ist ein Bergsteiger
ums Leben gekommen.
Am späten Abend
erreichte der Notruf Lukla.
Nun soll Siddartha
ins Lager 2 auf 6'400 m fliegen,
um die Leiche zu bergen.
Ich habe gehört, er sei Amerikaner,
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Offenbar hatte er vorgestern
eine Herzattacke im Lager 3.
Die Sherpas brachten ihn ins Camp 2,
und wir werden ihn dort abholen.
Es wird das erste Mal sein,
dass Siddartha ohne die Unterstützung
von Gerold auf 6'400 m fliegt,
dort landet und wieder startet.
Konzentriert macht er sich bereit.
Wir versuchen, den Helikopter
so leicht wie möglich zu machen,
damit wir in der Höhe
mehr Kraftreserven haben.
Es sollte uns so auch möglich sein,
einen Körper zu transportieren.
Wie sieht euer Plan aus?
Wir werden in Camp 2 landen.
Die Sherpas
werden uns den Körper aufladen.
So sieht unser Plan aus.
Wie fühlst du dich dabei,
eine Leiche herunterzuholen?
Eine Erfahrung.
Kommen keine Emotionen auf?
Da kommen keine Emotionen auf.
Es ist unser Job, dorthin zu fliegen
und sie herunterzuholen.
Von aussen
sieht ein Einsatz total anders aus,
als wenn man beteiligt ist.
Wenn man mitten drin steckt,
muss man an so viele Dinge denken
und etwas tun,
auch wenn man sich manchmal
seiner Sache nicht sicher ist.
Man musssich für etwas entscheiden.
Nicht zu handeln, ist keine Option.
Man muss eine Entscheidung fällen,
egal ob sie gut oder schlecht ist.
Aber man hofft natürlich,
das Richtige zu tun.
Funkspruch
Vor Siddartha türmt sich schon bald
der Everest mit seinen 8'850 m auf.
Die Bergung des toten Bergsteigers
ist ein gefährlicher Einsatz
in eisigen Höhen.
Während Siddartha unterwegs ist,
ist in Lukla
ein verletzter Bergsteiger
aus dem Basislager des Everest
gelandet.
Sein Name ist Michael Gibbons.
Er hatte Glück.
Er fiel in eine Gletscherspalte,
konnte aber gerettet werden
und wartet nun mit einem gebrochenen
Arm
auf den Weitertransport nach
Kathmandu und zurück nach Amerika.
Du hattest Glück.
Die andere Person musste sterben.
Es ist eine Gratwanderung.
Du bist in eine Spalte gefallen.
Es hätte auch schlimm enden können.
Denkst du darüber nach?
Ich versuche,
nicht zu sehr darüber nachzudenken.
Man trainiert ja
sehr hart,
um dann an einem Berg
wie diesem erfolgreich zu sein.
Dann übergibst du dich und deine
Leistungen in Gottes Hände
und hoffst, dass alles gut kommt.
Siddartha nähert sich
inzwischen seinem Ziel -
alleine und konzentriert.
Funkspruch
Ich fliege jetzt
über das Basecamp auf 6'000 m.
Jetzt bin ich
über dem Khumbu-Eisfall.
Auf einer Flughöhe von 6'500 m
fliegt Siddartha
über das Lager 1
ins Tal des Schweigens.
Camp 2, könnt ihr mich hören?
Siddartha, ich glaube Camp 2
kann nicht antworten.
Weit unter ihm kämpfen sich
in einer Kolonne Bergsteiger
mühsam über Gletscherspalten
und Eisfelder zum Lager 2 hoch.
Roger, ich drehe jetzt ab.
Wirst du landen?
- Ich werde jetzt landen.
Siddartha
nähert sich Lager 2 auf 6'400 m -
eine weitere Zeltstadt
auf Eis und Schnee
mit Hunderten von Kletterern
auf dem Weg zum Gipfel des Everests.
Die Sherpas warten mit der Leiche
des Bergsteigers am Ende des Lagers.
Die Windverhältnisse sind gut.
Die Leiche ist meine Referenz.
Siddartha darf sich nun
bei der Landung in dieser Höhe
keinen Fehler leisten.
Ich bin unten.
Er landet sicher,
die Sherpas heben den toten
Bergsteiger in den Helikopter.
Siddartha lässt die Rotoren laufen.
Okay Jungs, ich hebe ab.
Nur langsam hebt der Helikopter
mit dem zusätzlichen Gewicht
vom Boden ab.
Die Rotoren haben nicht mehr genug
Luft unter den Tragflächen,
um weiter zu steigen.
Siddartha schwebt mit seiner Last
tief über das Lager 2.
Ich bin weg und sicher.
Spannende Musik
Ich fliege jetzt nach Pheriche.
Hast du die Leiche?
- Ich habe die Leiche
und fliege damit nach Pheriche.
Dann weiter nach Lukla.
Thank you.
Den Bergsteigern
ist oft nicht bewusst,
welche Risiken die Piloten
auf sich nehmen, um sie zu retten
oder sie im schlimmsten Fall
tot zu bergen.
Der verunglückte Bergsteiger
heisst Rick Hitch.
Nur 2 Tage zuvor
hatte er hier am Everest
seinen 55. Geburtstag gefeiert.
Er war kein Anfänger. Nein.
Mit dem Mount Everest wollte er sich
einen lange gehegten Traum erfüllen.
Es wäre sein letzter Gipfel
der 7 summits,
der 7 höchsten Berge der Welt,
gewesen.
Ein Traum, für den er sterben musste.
Wie Michael Gibbons
stammte auch er aus Kalifornien.
Statt auf dem Gipfel des Everests
zu stehen,
wird seine Leiche nun zurück nach
Amerika zu seiner Familie geflogen.
Ins Camp 2 hoch ging es gut.
Ich hatte genügend Kraftreserven.
Die Leiche von dort
hinunter zu tragen,
wäre für die Sherpas
sehr hart gewesen.
Mit dem Helikopter ist es einfacher.
Ich glaube, sie sind erleichtert,
dass sie die Leiche nicht
vom Camp 2 hinuntertragen mussten.
Es war also für sie wie für uns
eine gute Sache.
Bis ins Camp 2
ist es für uns völlig okay,
eine bis 2 Personen herunterzuholen,
ob es sich nun um einen Notfall
oder um eine Leiche handelt.
Ich bin zufrieden.
Die Verhältnisse waren gut.
Das Wetter war mir freundlich
gesinnt, ich bin sehr dankbar.
Leben und Tod liegen in der Welt
der 8'000er nahe beieinander.
Oft ist es Glück oder eben Schicksal,
wer überlebt oder stirbt.
Als ich sah, wie sie die Leiche
dieses Mannes ausgeladen haben,
fühlte ich Trauer in mir.
Aber da ich ein Christ bin,
habe ich Vertrauen,
dass er jetzt im Himmel ist.
Er ist mit Gott.
Michael Gibbons Everest Abenteuer
ist aber nur scheinbar zu Ende:
In Amerika finden die Ärzte heraus,
dass der Arm nicht gebrochen ist.
Sofort fliegt Gibbons
zurück nach Nepal,
chartert einen Helikopter
ins Basecamp
und steht am 21. Mai doch noch
auf dem Gipfel seiner Träume.
Sieht so die Zukunft der
Helikopterrettung im Himalaya aus?
Kein Bergsteiger
darf so vermessen sein,
einfach in die Berge zu gehen und
zu hoffen, dass ihm nichts passiert.
Und wenn etwas passiert,
auf einen Helikopter hoffen,
der einen herunterholt.
Wer so in die Berge geht,
hat hier nichts verloren.
Nehmen die Bergsteiger
nicht mehr Risiko auf sich,
weil sie wissen,
sie werden per Helikopter gerettet?
Genau diese Frage wird bei uns
immer wieder gestellt.
Es heisst dann:
"Ihr mit euren modernen Rettungen
animiert die Leute,
in die Berge zu gehen."
Das mag vielleicht richtig sein,
aber es gibt keine Garantie,
dass wir ihn lebend zurückbringen.
Es sind andere Gesetze, die hier
bestimmen. Auch im Himalaya.
Es gibt Menschen, die Pech haben,
die sog. Pechunfälle haben.
Unsere Aufgabe ist es,
diesen zu helfen.
Auch in Nepal
müssen wir ihnen helfen.
Wenn einer aufgrund dieses
Rettungssystems mehr Risiko eingeht,
dann ist das
sein persönliches Problem.
Ob er dann gerettet wird,
ist eine andere Frage.
Der Himalaya ist in dieser Hinsicht
ein anderes paar Schuhe.
Davon zeugt auch
ihr nächster Einsatz,
der sie weg vom Everest
in den Westen Nepals
zum 8'156 m hohen Manaslu führt,
wo sie die Leiche eines Koreaners
bergen sollen.
Sie landen in Samagaun,
einem kleinen Dorf auf 3'390 m.
Vor einem Jahr war eine koreanische
Expedition am Manaslu in Not.
Sie riefen die Bergretter.
2 Bergsteiger konnten damals
lebend geborgen werden,
2 blieben verschollen.
Nun wurde einer gefunden.
Der Pilot Dani Aufdenblatten,
der die Aktion
bereits letzes Jahr flog,
übernimmt die Verantwortung.
Wir gehen jetzt hinauf,
um zu sehen, wie es ist.
Als Erstes nehme ich Bruno mit.
Bruno war vor 30 Jahren selber
an einer Expedition am Manaslu.
Herrgott, all diese Leute hier!
Letztes Mal waren viel weniger hier.
Ich glaube,
ich sehe sie hier vorne stehen.
Schau, er liegt hier oben.
Jemand hat uns Platz gemacht.
Tipptopp.
Die Koreaner haben dieses Jahr
eine spezielle Expedition
auf die Beine gestellt,
um ihre vermissten Kollegen zu
suchen. Gefunden haben sie nur einen.
Ich steige aus.
3 Sherpas
haben die Leiche des Koreaners
auf einem Zwischenplatz in 6'400 m
Höhe zum Abtransport bereit gemacht.
Bruno bleibt zurück
und koordiniert die Bergung
des koreanischen Bergsteigers
namens Park Hang Sue,
während Dani abhebt,
um Tshering zu holen.
Ein Jahr lang lag Park Hang Sue
unter Eis und Schnee
auf 7'400 m begraben.
Wir Sherpas gingen hoch,
packten die Leiche ein
und brachten sie herunter.
Es war sehr schwierig,
sie herunterzutragen.
Aber jetzt können wir sie
zum Glück ausfliegen lassen.
Über 1'000 Höhenmeter haben die
Sherpas den toten Bergsteiger Park
über Gletscherspalten und Eisabbrüche
runtergeschleppt,
z.T. unter Einsatz
ihres eigenen Lebens.
Ja, das ist ein ungeheurer Krampf.
Ihn hinunterzutragen,
ist ein extremer Krampf.
Das ist extrem.
Sie haben zum Glück
einen guten Schlitten.
Sie haben zwei Fässer aufgetrennt,
und einer zieht ihn nun hinunter.
Seinen Kollegen
haben die Sherpas nicht gefunden,
dafür einen iranischen Bergsteiger,
der vor 3 Tagen hier gestorben ist.
Sie begruben ihn im Schnee
gleich neben Park Hang Sue.
Inzwischen wird auch Tshering
zum Platz auf 6'400 m geflogen.
25'000 $ haben
die Angehörigen von Park Hang Sue
für die Suchexpedition und
die Bergung per Helikopter bezahlt -
hätten seine Familie und Freunde
nicht darauf bestanden,
ihn zu suchen und zu bergen,
wäre er auf über 7'000 m geblieben.
Park wäre einer
der vielen unbekannten Toten,
die auf den Bergriesen des Himalaya
herumliegen.
Viele Leichen werden nie geborgen,
weil es bisher ohne Helikopter
in der dünnen Luft zu gefährlich
und zu anstrengend war, sie aus
den eisigen Höhen herunterzuholen.
Zurück bleibt der Iraner,
begraben im Schnee,
und dort bleibt er, solange niemand
dafür bezahlt, ihn zu bergen.
Tshering hofft,
dass man in Zukunft Bergsteiger
wie ihn lebend retten kann.
Es wäre schön gewesen,
wenn sie uns früher gerufen hätten.
Gleich als es geschah.
So hätten wir es
zumindest versuchen können.
In Nepal wissen viele noch nicht,
welche Technologien
es hier schon gibt.
In Zukunft
müssen alle Trekkingagenturen
an das Leben der Leute denken
und nicht ans Geld.
In Samagaun haben die Freunde
des verstorbenen Bergsteigers Pak
eine buddhistische Feier vorbereitet,
um sich von ihm zu verabschieden:
Melancholisch-düstere Musik
Beobachtet von der Dorfbevölkerung,
die staunend
die Trauer der Bergsteiger miterlebt.
Sie seien dankbar,
meinen die Bergsteiger,
dass ihr toter Freund nun
zu seiner Familie nach Korea geflogen
und würdig bestattet werden könne.
Nach wie vor werden sehr viele Leute
im Himalaya sterben.
Der Helikopter
ist eigentlich nur ein Hilfsmittel,
um den Leuten Hilfe zu bringen.
Und so muss man das auch sehen.
Dass es noch ein langer Weg ist
bis v.a. auch
die einheimische Bevölkerung
von den Helikoptereinsätzen
profitieren kann, das zeigt sich,
als das Rettungsteam wieder zurück
nach Lukla ins Everestgebiet fliegt.
Wie immer herrscht auf dem Flugplatz
Hochbetrieb -
Flieger landen und starten
im Minutentakt.
Für Trekker und Bergsteiger ist es
der Ausgangpunkt ihrer Abenteuer.
Es ist ein Ort, wo sich westliche
Reisende Wünsche und Träume
von hohen Bergen
und magischen Landschaften erfüllen,
wo aber auch
arm und reich aufeinandertreffen.
Funkspruch
Wir starten die Motoren.
Wir heben ab von Lukla,
Richtung Kare auf 5'500 m.
Siddartha startet gemeinsam mit Bruno
zu einem kommerziellen Flug.
Sie haben den Auftrag,
in Kare, einem Weiler am Mera,
auf 5'500 m
eine Gruppe von Trekkern abzuholen,
die den 2-tägigen Marsch
zurück nach Lukla
nicht mehr auf sich nehmen will.
Bruno, hörst du mich?
Es sind 4 Leute.
3 Leute bitte für den ersten Flug.
3 Leute drinnen
und einer für den 2. Flug. Okay?
Okay, that's good.
Kann ich die Türe öffnen,
um nach dem Heck zu schauen?
Noch einen halben Meter
bis zum Kontakt.
Kann ich jetzt aussteigen?
Yes, Bruno.
Siddartha landet,
und Bruno organisiert den Rückflug
für die Gruppe.
Es sind russische Touristen.
Bruno, 3 Leute zuerst.
Aus Gewichtsgründen nimmt Siddartha
nur 3 Touristen
im ersten Flug nach Lukla mit.
On board! On board!
Wir versuchen, 3 Leute einzuladen.
Aber die Kommunikation
ist etwas schwierig.
Bruno, it's good?
Business as usual,
aber v.a. ein gutes Geschäft
für die Helikopterfirmen.
Wer es sich leisten kann,
nimmt den Dienst in Anspruch.
Da wir ihn anbieten,
haben wir auch Kunden,
die davon profitieren wollen.
Der Rettungsdienst
ist also für die Helikopterfirmen
ein grosses Geschäft.
Doch für die arme Bevölkerung
gelten andere Gesetze.
Auf dem Flughafen von Lukla liegt
seit dem frühen Morgen Kali Sherpa.
Er wartet zwischen startenden
und landenden Touristen
auf einen Flug ins Spital
nach Kathmandu.
Seine Verwandten
trugen ihn 3 Tage lang
auf dieser behelfsmässigen Bahre
nach Lukla.
Er ist beim Reparieren des Daches
heruntergefallen
und hat sich das
das Rückgrat gebrochen.
Wir brachten ihn nach Kathmandu,
wo er 2 Monate im Krankenhaus war.
Jetzt geht es ihm wieder schlecht.
Er hat Schmerzen im Unterleib.
Ist es schwierig für einen Patienten,
der so abgelegen lebt?
Ja, natürlich. Man kriegt
nicht einfach so ein Flugticket.
Ich versuche seit 2 Tagen,
ein Notfall-Ticket zu bekommen,
aber es gibt keines.
Seine Bauchseite
ist furchtbar angeschwollen.
Es wäre für ihn
eine grosse Erleichterung,
wenn er baldmöglichst
ins Krankenhaus könnte.
Geld spielt für die Touristen, die
Siddartha zurückbringt, keine Rolle.
There we are, turning left.
Rund 8'000 $ lassen sie sich
ihren Taxiflug nach Lukla
und darauf nach Kathmandu kosten.
Nur gerade 100 m weiter entfernt
wartet Kali Sherpa immer noch.
Er spricht
eine nepalesische Sprache.
Er kann uns nicht hören,
aber sprechen kann er gut.
Er will nicht nach Kathmandu.
Er sagt,
die Behandlung koste zu viel Geld.
Allein der Flug nach Kathmandu
kostet 80 $.
Derweil gelöste Ferienstimmung
bei den russischen Touristen.
Planten sie immer,
mit dem Helikopter zurückzufliegen?
Nein, es ist unser erstes Mal.
Das erste Mal,
dass wir den Helikopter benützen.
Warum benutzt ihr ihn dieses Mal?
Weil wir ...
... schneller zurück sein wollten.
Erst jetzt, nachdem alle Touristen
gelandet und abgeflogen sind,
hat es auch für Kali Sherpa
Platz im Flugzeug.
Flug und Spitalaufenthalt
berappen seine Tochter und der
Schwiegersohn aus ihren Ersparnissen,
denn versichert sind sie alle nicht.
Es ist dieser Gegensatz
von arm und reich,
der auch Bruno Jelk beschäftigt.
Das sollte in Zukunft
nicht mehr passieren.
Wir sollten eine Lösung finden,
damit die finanziellen Mittel
zur Verfügung stehen,
um solche Transporte zu erledigen.
Für unser Image
wäre das ein grosser Vorteil.
Für mich persönlich
ist es hart zu sehen,
dass man reiche Touristen holt, nur
weil sie zu faul zum Laufen sind.
Daneben gibt es kranke Leute,
die nur aus finanziellen Gründen,
und nicht wegen andern Dingen,
nicht in ein Spital kommen.
Um der einfachen Bevölkerung
zu helfen,
gewähren die Helikopterfirmen
den einfachen Leuten
zwar 50 % Preisnachlass
oder nehmen sie gratis mit,
falls sie Platz haben.
Wir müssen einen Weg finden,
solche Einsätze zu finanzieren,
entweder auf lokalpolitischer Ebene
oder durch andere Einsätze,
die wir leisten,
wie die Touristenrettungsflüge.
Das sind 2 Möglichkeiten,
solche Einsätze zu finanzieren.
Ein Grossteil der Bevölkerung Nepals
lebt nicht in Kathmandu,
sondern in einfachsten Verhältnissen
abgeschieden auf dem Lande.
Das Durchschnittseinkommen pro Jahr
liegt bei rund 400 $ pro Person.
Immer öfter haben Helikopterfirmen
Aufträge in abgelegene Regionen.
So auch dieses Mal.
Heute sollen Kabel für Hängebrücken
in abgelegene Täler
transportiert werden.
Der Gegensatz zwischen modernem
und einfachem Leben
könnte nicht grösser sein
und scheint sich
nicht mehr aufhalten zu lassen.
Sanfte Musik
Mit der Globalisierung
verändert sich die ganze Welt.
Nehmen wir das Mobiltelefon.
Auch in Nepal haben 7 von 10 Leuten
ein Mobiltelefon,
sogar in abgelegenen Gegenden.
Alles verändert sich.
Man kann den Leuten nicht befehlen,
sich nicht weiterzuentwickeln.
Die Menschen müssen sich anpassen,
sonst werden sie nicht überleben.
Neben Rettungen
sind Transporte wie diese
ein lohnendes Geschäft
für Fishtail Air.
Rund 50'000 $
verdienen sie mit diesem Auftrag,
der von der Regierung kommt.
Die Regierung
leistet Entwicklungshilfe
in den Regionen und in den Dörfern.
Sie versuchen,
Brücken in dieser Gegend zu bauen,
weil es ohne Brücken
für die Leute sehr gefährlich ist,
sich dort zu bewegen.
Wir transportieren
die Kabel für die Brücken.
Die Kabel hierher zu tragen,
wäre sehr schwierig.
Für ein Kabel
bräuchte man etwa 30 Leute,
die in einer langen Linie
mit den Seilen auf der Schulter
gefährliche Stellen
passieren müssen.
Mit dem Helikopter
wird es einfacher für sie.
Und für Siddartha ist es ein
ideales Training mit der Longline.
Okay, es ist befestigt,
du kannst hochfliegen.
Was so einfach scheint,
entpuppt sich plötzlich
als ein Auftrag mit einigen Tücken.
Oh, 500 kg!
Zu ihrer Überraschung sind die Kabel
viel schwerer als geplant.
500.
540. Nicht 300.
Nein.
Es sollte nicht so sein.
Es ist wie zu Hause.
Sie sagten 300 kg,
aber es waren mehr als 500.
Ja, aber ... es ist nur ein Kabel.
Der Heli kommt an seine Grenzen.
Spannende Musik
Wenn es schwierig wird,
werf ich das Kabel einfach ab.
Die Pferde rennen einfach davon.
Wir lassen es runter.
Warte, warte!
Okay, Kontakt? Kontakt.
Alles gut. Es gibt keine Probleme.
Steigen wir aus?
Ja. Sofort aussteigen.
Geht es gut?
Ja.
So, das war sowas
wie ein kontrollierter Crash.
Zusammen mit der schweren Last
bleibt auch Bruno
im Dorf Samdo zurück.
Es liegt auf knapp 4'000 m Höhe
an der Grenze zu Tibet
und ist 8 Tagesmärsche
von der Zivilisation entfernt.
Das gebe ich ihr.
Hier kommt die andere Seite von Bruno
zum Tragen,
die nichts mit ihm
als wortkargen Bergretter zu tun hat.
Er hat einen Sack
voll Kleider und Spielzeuge aus der
Schweiz mitgebracht, die er verteilt.
Okay?
Sanft-berührende Musik
Das mache ich gerne.
Ich mache das immer.
Bei jeder Gelegenheit
nehme ich Kleider mit,
aber man hat halt immer zu wenig.
Man kann nicht mehr mitnehmen.
Wenigstens etwas.
Und ich habe höllische Freude.
Aber man kann
nicht alle glücklich machen.
Seit fast 30 Jahren komme er nach
Nepal, als Bergsteiger oder Trekker
und während dieser Zeit
sei ihm die Bevölkerung
einfach ans Herz gewachsen, meint er.
Er sei selber
unter einfachsten Bedingungen
in den Freiburger Alpen aufgewachsen,
Das Volk bedeutet mir etwas.
Nicht nur in Nepal, auch in Peru.
Zwar ist Peru etwas weiterentwickelt
als Nepal.
Tibet ist dasselbe.
Ich bin der Meinung, dass man
den Leuten das verteilen sollte,
was wir nicht mehr brauchen.
Inzwischen
geht Siddarthas Arbeit weiter:
Stahlkabelrollen anhängen,
abfliegen in die Täler -
immer beobachtet von der Bevölkerung,
die daran gewohnt ist,
ihre Lasten selber zu tragen.
Wie in den Alpen,
können durch Lastflüge
die Täler besser erschlossen werden,
aber es stellt sich die Frage,
ob der Helikopter den Einheimischen
nicht auch Arbeit wegnimmt.
Bei solchen schweren Lasten hat man
keine Chancen, es selbst zu tun.
Wenn es
um den Materialtransport geht,
muss man sich schon überlegen,
ob das gut ist.
So macht man viele arbeitslos.
Aber ich glaube ...
... das hier
ist sicher nicht das Problem.
Es kommt darauf an, wie die Menschen
mit den Neuerungen umgehen
und wie sie die alten Traditionen
bewahren können.
Vielleicht gibt es in Nepal
eine Mischung
zwischen neuer Kultur
und alter Kultur.
Dann könnten die Menschen das Beste
von beidem für sich herausnehmen.
Es wäre gut, wenn ihnen das gelänge.
Wie in der Schweiz
vor 50 oder 60 Jahren.
Da haben die Menschen
vielleicht ähnlich wie in Nepal
die neuen Technologien
mit den alten Traditionen verbunden
und das sehr gut gemacht.
Wenn das in Nepal auch klappt,
wäre das sehr gut.
Dann passiert das, worauf sich
alle hier vorbereitet haben:
ein Notruf am 8'000er Manaslu,
doch die Retter hängen
im Nebel von Kathmandu fest.
Zwei französische Bergsteiger
und ein Sherpa werden vermisst.
Und zwar zwischen Lager 4
und Lager 3.
Das ist zwischen 7'400 m
und 6'800 m.
Als sich der Nebel über Kathmandu
lichtet und das Team abfliegt,
wissen sie immer noch nicht,
wo sich die Bergsteiger
am 8'000er Manaslu befinden.
Die Überlebenschancen
für die französischen Bergsteiger
und ihre Sherpas
sind nach 2 Nächten auf über 7'000 m
zwar gering, aber noch intakt.
Jedoch nur,
wenn sie schnell gefunden werden.
Dafür müssen die Bergretter
einmal mehr über sich hinaus wachsen.
Ich gehe mit dem Helikopter ...
... an die Grenze des Zugelassenen.
Ich fühle mich okay.
Hoffentlich bleibt das Wetter so.
Wenn das Wetter so bleibt, ist das
die goldene Chance, sie zu finden.
Aber ich denke,
bald wird es bedeckt sein.
Also müssen wir uns beeilen.
Wie viel Kilo nehmt ihr da etwa raus?
Ich schätze
so zwischen 50 und 60 kg.
50 bis 60 kg.
Das gibt mir
hoffentlich die Reserve,
dass ich hier oben schweben kann.
Imposanter,
eindrücklicher Chorgesang
So hoch wie bei diesem Einsatz
sind sie noch nie geflogen.
Die Bergsteiger wurden
auf 7'400 m als vermisst gemeldet.
Now we can go.
Gerold startet mit Bruno und Tshering
die Suche nach den Vermissten,
den 2 französischen Bergsteigern
und ihren Sherpas.
Gefilmt von einer Kamera
im Parallelhelikopter,
den Siddartha fliegt,
und einer fix installierten Kamera
im Helikopter
von Gerold, Tshering und Bruno.
Ich erreiche jetzt 5'200 m.
Ich denke, es geht gut.
Ich bin jetzt auf 5'600.
Es ist absolut kein Problem.
Wir erreichen Camp 1.
Ich sehe die Zelte.
In Wirklichkeit sind wir
wahrscheinlich schon auf 6'100 m.
Wir sehen Spuren.
Hast du etwas gesehen?
Hier.
Wir können Spuren sehen
auf der linken Seite.
Ich sehe jetzt
auch das Zelt von Camp 2.
Ich sehe einen Mann
an meiner rechten Seite.
Da sitzt er.
Er klettert runter.
Auf rund 6'400 m entdecken sie
einen Sherpa im Abstieg,
den sie aber noch zurücklassen,
in der Hoffnung, andere Überlebende
weiter oben zu finden.
Wir steigen jetzt auf über 7'000 m.
Sehen wir nach dem Camp 4!
Fliegen wir zu den höher gelegenen
Camps, um weiter zu suchen!
Wir gehen hoch.
Es hat starken Wind.
Rauf auf über 7'000 m Höhe ―
so hoch war Gerold noch nie.
Ich erreiche jetzt 6'700.
Ja, hier sind die Zelte.
2 Zelte von Camp 3 kann ich sehen.
Aber keine anderen Zeichen.
Hast du was gesehen?
Unter uns habe ich einen gesehen.
Unter uns ist einer!
Wir haben womöglich
jemanden gesichtet,
der weit vom Weg abgekommen ist.
Bruno, wo hast du ihn gesehen?
Hier oben auf dieser Höhe.
Ich habe etwas Rotes gesehen.
Bruno hat etwas gesehen,
aber wir wissen nicht genau was.
Aber der ist tot, oder?
Ja. Er bewegt sich nicht mehr.
Wir haben vermutlich
einen Toten gesichtet.
Und oberhalb von Camp 4 ist niemand.
Abgesehen von einem toten Bergsteiger
haben sie niemanden gefunden.
Okay, es macht keinen Sinn.
Gehen wir wieder runter.
Wir sehen nichts hier.
Sie kehren zurück zum Sherpa,
der immer noch im Abstieg ist.
Bruno, soll ich Tshering reinnehmen?
Ja, das ist gut.
Are you ready, guys?
Jetzt müssen wir uns beeilen,
sonst kann er nicht mehr.
Ist gut.
Tshering hängt sich unten im Seil ein
und soll von Gerold zum nepalesischen
Kollegen geflogen werden,
der am Ende seiner Kräfte ist.
Ich hänge am Seil.
Alles okay? 1, 2, 3?
Alles gut, danke.
Dann können wir vielleicht
die Tasche holen.
Dann bring ich sie zu dir
und dann entscheide ich,
ob wir 2 nehmen können.
Einen halben Meter.
Okay, alles gut.
Okay,
nun fliege ich dich zum Sherpa.
Ich fliege dich direkt zu ihm.
30 m unten am Seil
nähert sich Tshering dem Sherpa.
Gerold versucht,
den Helikopter in der dünnen Luft
auf 6'400 m ruhig zu halten
und Tshering präzise
zwischen den Eisabbrüchen abzusetzen.
Dramatische Musik
Einen halben Meter zurück ...
Position halten!
Der Sherpa ist angehängt.
Okay, versuchen wir es!
Bist du bereit?
Sherpa ist bereit, Captain.
Nach 2 Nächten in über 7'000 m
hängt der Sherpa unten am Helikopter
in Sicherheit.
Okay, wir bringen den Sherpa runter
und holen Tshering.
Aus Gewichtsgründen
musste Gerold Tshering zurücklassen.
Okay, copy that.
Hast du beide dran?
Nein, nur einen.
Am Zwischenlandeplatz
nimmt Bruno den Sherpa in Empfang.
Gerold fliegt gleich wieder ab,
um Tshering zu holen,
der erfolgreich das Leben
eines Kollegen gerettet hat.
Alles ist so abgelaufen,
wie es die Bergretter
immer wieder trainiert haben.
Was hier so routiniert wirkt,
ist in Wirklichkeit ein Einsatz
an der Grenze des Möglichen.
Dies zeigt sich beim Abflug.
Mit 4 Personen an Bord ist der
Helikopter in über 6'000 m am Limit.
Gerold kann kaum mehr steigen.
Er lässt den Helikopter über
die Eiskuppe in die Tiefe sinken.
Aber die Bergretter
haben ein Menschenleben gerettet.
Eine weitere Nacht in eisiger Höhe
hätte für den Sherpa
fatale Folgen gehabt.
Zudem hat das Team der Bergretter
seine Feuertaufe bestanden.
Tshering, wie wars?
Sorry?
How did it go?
Es ging sehr gut.
Mit diesem starken
technischen System.
Wir flogen sehr hoch hinauf.
Das System ist perfekt,
keine Probleme.
Das war dein erster Einsatz.
Bist du stolz?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Aber das war Dank dem guten Lehrer.
Da gibt es keinen Zweifel.
Ja, er ist ein guter Lehrer.
Das ist super, was er macht.
Ihr müsst auch nicht mehr
in die Berge kommen.
Er kann das problemlos.
Schau! 7'100 ...
7'100?
Mit dem Helikopter?
Ja, noch höher.
7'100. Das ist gut.
Sehr hoch.
Sehr hoch, ja.
Tshering und Siddartha,
der mit dem Kameraheli
auch bis 7'000 m geflogen ist,
stehen am Ende ihrer Ausbildung.
I was not sure
if you could land next to me.
We would have changed the chopper.
Ich bilde sehr viele Leute aus,
aber ein solches Projekt innerhalb
kurzer Zeit realisieren zu können,
war eine Befriedigung.
Zumal wir massiv
in der Kritik standen.
Alle waren überzeugt,
dass es nicht klappen würde,
dass sie es nie lernen würden.
Das war ein noch grösserer Ansporn.
Für uns selber, aber auch um ihnen
zu beweisen, dass sie das schaffen.
Inzwischen ist ein Jahr vergangen.
Mit Siddartha und Tshering haben
die Zermatter ein Team ausgebildet,
das im Himalaya selbständig
Menschenleben retten kann.
Immer noch fehlen in Nepal
aber weiteres Know-how,
Material und finanzielle Mittel.
Die Zermatter haben inzwischen
eine Stiftung gegründet,
damit der Traum weitergeht.
Das ferne Ziel wird sein,
dass wir irgendwann
Ärzte in die Täler fliegen können,
die z.B. eine Woche hierbleiben
und sich um diese Leute kümmern.
Dass sie einen Arztdienst haben,
und in einem nächsten Schritt
medizinisch gut und korrekt
versorgt werden.
Dank des Geldes aus der Stiftung
flogen Bruno und ein Pilot
der Air Zermatt
im Frühling wieder nach Lukla,
um Tshering und Siddartha
weiter zu instruieren
und neues Rettungsmaterial
aus der Schweiz zu bringen.
Zudem fliegt Siddartha neu
mit Simrik Air,
einer aufstrebenden Helikopterfirma
in Nepal,
mit einem potenten Geldgeber.
Dieser will mit Siddartha
und Tshering
in die Helikopterrettung
in Nepal investieren
und ein Team aufbauen,
das Zukunft hat.
Es braucht Zeit,
vielleicht 5 - 10 Jahre.
Wenn wir es richtig machen,
motiviert sind
und alle gewissenhaft arbeiten,
dann werden wir
schon bald soweit sein.
Was ist dein Traum?
Mein Traum ist
gratis Helikopterrettung
für die gesamte Bevölkerung Nepals.
Es ist die Geschichte eines Traums,
der weitergeht
und bei dem v.a. 2 Menschen unver-
gessen bleiben:
Sabin und Purna.
Sie haben für den Traum
einer Rettungsstation im Himalaya
ihr Leben gelassen.
Es gibt Träume im Leben,
die lassen sich nur realisieren,
wenn der Mensch
über sich hinauswächst.
SWISS TXT / UT-Redaktion Zürich
Sabine Naepflin - 2012